[Music]
smallpox is an acute infectious disease
that today is a serious problem in asia
africa
[Music]
and south america
although smallpox is not primarily a
military problem it remains a potential
one
[Music]
there were 20 military cases with five
deaths during the korean conflict
it is however a serious problem when
considered globally
that is the spread of smallpox from
endemic areas to our civilian population
which even today is only partially
immunized
here's how it looks to the army medical
corps
when smallpox appears as a classical
textbook disease it's easily diagnosed
but if it is of the milder varial a
minor variety or is modified by previous
vaccination its clinical diagnosis is
quite difficult and often missed even by
physicians who are familiar with
smallpox the purpose of this film is to
show clinical manifestations of variola
major its various degrees of severity
and to point out differences between
variola major and the milder forms
variola minor and modified smallpox the
film demonstrates the differential
clinical and laboratory diagnosis of
smallpox and chickenpox
and shows procedures for treatment and
prophylaxis
including some recently developed
techniques
regardless of the severity of the
disease the onset of smallpox is the
same prodromal symptoms are sudden and
severe
after an incubation period of from 7 to
16 days usually 12 days a chill or in
children a convulsion is commonly the
first symptom
intense frontal headache and backache
are usually present
vomiting may occur
with the aid of animation let us pursue
this further
the temperature rises quickly to 103 to
105 degrees
muscles and joints hurt
probably the most common pre-eruptive
diagnosis is influenza
a prodromal flushing or rash may occur
the early symptoms have been diagnosed
as scarlet fever
measles
acute appendicitis
and cholecystitis
on the third or fourth day after onset
of symptoms
macules begin to appear on the forehead
lips
nose
cheeks
and chin
then they appear successfully on the
neck
chest
trunk
arms
and legs
and finally on the hands and feet
this order of invasion is not always
constant
prodromal symptoms may increase in
severity
immediately prior to the appearance of
the macular rash
but soon after its appearance the fever
subsides
and the patient feels better
on the second day of the rash
the macules become papules
on palpation
the papules feel round
hard
movable
and rolling under the finger
giving what has been called a shotty
feeling
within about 24 hours the papules
enlarge
and become filled with fluid to form
vesicles
the vesicles are multiloculated and have
dry depressed centers
resulting in a characteristic
umbilication
they appear to be in the skin
and not on its surface
about the fifth or sixth day of the rash
the vesicles become cloudy and the
pustular stage begins
a secondary rise in temperature and a
return of prodromal symptoms may
accompany the pustular stage
the pustules are gray yellow or pearly
in appearance
and are surrounded by erythematous
really that disappear upon pressure
characteristically
the pustules are distributed
centrifugally
that is
on the face
including lips
and on the extremities
exposed extensor surfaces and places
where the skin is tight such as wrists
are more apt to have pustules than our
flexor surfaces and the axilla
even in severe cases where the abdomen
and legs are heavily covered
there may be a relative sparsity of
lesions on the trunk
the pustules may become confluent
and the pain resulting from skin tension
can be quite severe
particularly when the face is swollen
concurrently
the mucous membranes of the mouth
eyes
and often the larynx may be involved
in fatal cases
death usually occurs in the second week
of the disease
about the eighth to tenth day of the
rash
the pustules rupture to form crusts that
remain intact a few days before becoming
dry and falling off
most of the crusts will have fallen off
by the third or fourth week
crust persist longest on the palms and
souls
and may have to be enucleated with a
needle
the degree of scarring depends on the
severity of the disease
and is usually most marked on the face
intense pigmentation of the skin lasts
for a variable time after the crusts
have dropped off
in darker skinned races
depigmentation occurs
this is variola major
or classical smallpox
there are degrees of severity beginning
with purpura variolosa or black smallpox
which occurs in patients with absolutely
no resistance
and is invariably fatal
in this type there may be hemorrhages
from all body orifices
and large perperic hemorrhages in the
skin
in many cases
death occurs before a rash appears
still very serious
but less severe
is the malignant confluent case
lesions are coalesced
soft
velvety
and do not have the pearly appearance
and hard shotty feeling of ordinary
smallpox pustules
the skin is hot and tender
and there may be hemorrhages into the
pustules and surrounding skin
the course of the illness is quite
stormy
and body temperature may remain elevated
the case fatality rate may be as low as
25 percent
or as high as 70 percent
depending somewhat on the extent of body
area covered with confluent lesions
less severe is the benign confluent case
in which lesions coalesce but retain
their ordinary hard feel and pearly
appearance
hemorrhage may occur into the lesions
and surrounding skin as in malignant
confluent smallpox
discrete smallpox
with no confluence
is still less severe
and is fatal in only 10 to 15 percent of
cases
the least severe form of variola major
is the abortive type
occurring in patients with good partial
immunity
and characterized by lack of confluence
and usually less than 20 pock marks on
the entire body
there may be no eruption at all
and the patient has only a mild
febrile illness
inapparent or subclinical infections
must be rare
lesser degrees of modification by
vaccination do occur
resulting in more severe disease
in contrast to variola major
there is the milder variola miner
believed to be caused by a slightly
different smallpox virus
this disease which rarely causes death
is also known as alastair
variola miner has severe prodromal
symptoms and in clinical appearance may
be indistinguishable from variola major
the lesions however progress more
rapidly and are more superficial that is
not so deep seated in the skin
in a study of more than 13 000 variola
minor cases by dr marsden in england it
was found that only 11
had pigmented scarring
scarring is the rule in variola major
in the same sample 87 had less than 100
pox on the face
only 19 patients had confluence
and only three had hemorrhagic lesions
in comparing variola major and minor
it's important to note that contacts of
variola major
no matter how mild the case will develop
severe variola major if they have no
immunity
contacts of cases of variola minor will
develop the same mild disease
with few exceptions
so there are many forms and degrees of
severity of smallpox
it is reasonable to say that except in a
typical well-developed case of classical
smallpox the clinical diagnosis is
unreliable
as in many other diseases in which the
patient has a vesicular eruption or for
that matter a rash
the best clue to a diagnosis
is a good history
since chickenpox or varicella is the
disease most often confused with
smallpox in a mild or modified form
it is well to review some differences
between these diseases
clinical differential diagnosis of
smallpox and chickenpox is often
difficult
and immigration authorities now tend to
quarantine all persons with vesicular
eruptions
there are however some differences
prodromal symptoms are quite severe in
smallpox
in chickenpox
they are mild
and often appear simultaneously with the
rash
the smallpox vesicle or pustule has a
hard base
and is in the deeper layers of the skin
the smallpox papule has a hard shotty
feeling
the chickenpox pustule appears to be on
the skin
and not in it
the chickenpox papule is soft
in smallpox lesions are in the same
stage of development on any one part of
the body
although different areas may be in
different stages of development
for example
the chest may have vesicular eruptions
while pustules appear on the arm
in chickenpox
lesions appear in crops
that is
papules
vesicles
and pustules may be present
simultaneously on the chest
it should be noted however
that such cropping
may occur in smallpox modified by
vaccination
distribution of lesions is another clue
in smallpox
lesions are distributed centrifugally
more lesions on the head and extremities
that on the trunk
in chickenpox
the reverse is true
more lesions on the trunk
it should be clear by now that suspicion
is one half the battle in diagnosing
smallpox
if the patient is from an endemic area
within the seven to sixteen day
incubation period
or if there is any doubt whatsoever
isolate the patient and obtain a
laboratory diagnosis
let's look now at some laboratory tests
and what they mean in terms of a
diagnosis
laboratory diagnosis is a specialized
procedure ordinarily necessary only for
the sporadic case of smallpox it is
based on the recovery and
characterization of variola virus from
vesicle fluid
skin scrapings or less commonly blood
and upon demonstration of rising
antibody titers during convalescence
variola virus is best recovered by
inoculation of the coriolentoic
membranes of 10-day embryonated eggs
the virological laboratory should be
consulted for technical details
concerning collection and shipment of
specimens
preliminary diagnosis may be attained by
examining stained smears of vesicle
fluid
the accuracy of this procedure is a
function of the microscopist's ability
to recognize the elementary bodies of
the variola vaccinia group of viruses
thus interpretation of such smears must
be made with caution
detection of elementary bodies allows a
provisional diagnosis that does not
distinguish between variola and vaccinia
but which does rule out chickenpox
a negative finding however does not rule
out the presence of variola
the complement fixation test for
detection of viral antigen in vesicle
fluid or crusts
can be made during all stages of the
disease
the test takes 24 hours
and is valuable in differential
diagnosis
because it distinguishes between the
variola vaccinia antigen
and those of chickenpox and herpes
simplex
it cannot however be used to distinguish
variola from vaccinia
and a negative test does not rule out
smallpox
differentiating variola from vaccinia
can be done only by recovery of virus
using the coriolentoic membrane of an
embryonated hens egg
the test
which can be made during all stages of
the disease
takes three to four days
lesions produced on the coriolentois
distinguish between variola vaccinia and
herpes simplex
lesions produced by variola major cannot
be distinguished from those of variola
minor chickenpox virus does not produce
lesions
a significant rise in antibodies to the
variola vaccinia group of viruses
is required before a complete ideologic
diagnosis can be made
neutralizing and hemagglutination
inhibiting antibodies
rise before complement fixing antibodies
in variola infections
neutralizing antibodies can be
demonstrated in previously vaccinated
patients after the third day of the
disease
and after the fifth or sixth day in
unvaccinated patients
hemagglutination inhibiting antibodies
can be detected as early as the third
day of the disease
almost coincident with the appearance of
the skin eruption
during the subsequent week there is
rapid rise in antibodies
in unvaccinated patients
the occurrence of hemoglobination
inhibiting antibodies
of moderately high titer
1 to 160 or above
in a single serum specimen
taken after the seventh day
permits a tentative diagnosis of
smallpox
a rise in hemagglutination inhibiting
antibodies in several successive daily
specimens within the first week
very strongly suggests the disease
detection of complement fixing
antibodies in previously vaccinated
patients after the sixth day
or in unvaccinated patients after the
tenth day
similarly suggests variola
all serological results must be
interpreted with due consideration of
the patient's clinical and epidemiologic
history
the infectivity of smallpox has probably
been exaggerated
transmission for short distances by
droplets from the upper respiratory
tract is the most common means of
transmission
ordinarily the range of infectiousness
is limited to the immediate vicinity of
the patient
the greatest danger of spreading the
disease comes from the unrecognized mild
case
let's look now at some procedures for
treating smallpox patients
and stopping the spread of infection
isolate the patient using ordinary
isolation procedures
re-vaccinate all attendance and require
visitors to show proof of vaccination
within the past six months
should a case be inadvertently admitted
to a general medical or surgical ward
vaccinate all staff personnel and
patients
including newborn infants
make a determined search for the source
of infection
locate all possible contacts
and keep them under surveillance for 16
days from the date of last exposure
isolate possible contacts if they show
any rise in temperature
at this time there is no proven specific
treatment for smallpox
good nursing care is essential to
prevent secondary bacterial infection of
the skin lesions
appropriate antibiotics may be used when
this occurs
maintenance of good fluid and
electrolyte balance is necessary as in
any serious illness
vaccination is the only effective means
for preventing smallpox
the procedure induces a primary
vaccination reaction called vaccinia in
a completely susceptible subject
observe this time-lapse study of a
typical reaction
vaccinia is a mild self-limited disease
recovery from which almost invariably
protects the subject from smallpox
infection for at least a year
and usually for several years
regulations call for vaccination of
military personnel every three years
within area r
namely u.s canada great britain and
australia
each year if they are living outside
area r
and for immediate vaccination regardless
of history in the face of an outbreak of
smallpox
vaccination of a smallpox case early
during incubation period may attenuate
the disease but this cannot be dependent
upon
recently there have been some field
trials in madras india
of a british developed drug called n
methylistan beta thiosemic carbozone
or more conveniently 33 t-57
the drug was given orally
usually for four days
to contacts of smallpox patients between
eight and eleven days after exposure
the results are as yet somewhat
inconclusive since dosages and the
duration of treatment varied
but they are encouraging
we will see now how smallpox vaccine is
prepared and administered
and how the vaccination reaction is
evaluated
freeze-dried vaccine is used exclusively
in the united states army because of its
prolonged potency greater stability and
ease of storage
the freeze-dried kit contains a 10 dose
vial of dried vaccine
a syringe filled with penalized
glycerinated reconstituting fluid
a plastic dispensing tip
a protective cover for the dispenser
and vaccinating needles
before reconstitution freeze dried
vaccine should be stored in a household
type refrigerator but it should not be
frozen
where refrigeration is unavailable it
may be left at room temperature
vaccine must be reconstituted and used
on or before the expiration date which
is on the package
this is presently 18 months after date
of manufacture
reconstituted smallpox vaccine should
also be stored at normal refrigerator
temperatures
it may be used up to seven days after
reconstitution
before preparing the vaccine mark the
date of reconstitution on the syringe
to prepare the vaccine remove the tip of
the syringe
then insert it at the back as a plunger
clean the top of the vial with acetone
inject the reconstituting fluid into the
vial
reconstitution of the ten dose vial
takes about one minute with gentle
shaking
draw the vaccine into the syringe
then thread the plastic dispensing tip
over the needle
cover the dispenser with the protective
cover when not in use
would you step up here please
the deltoid region of the arm is the
usual site for vaccination
swab the area with acetone and allow to
dry
alcohol kills the virus and must never
be used
place one drop of reconstituted vaccine
on the prepared site
do not inject the contents of the vial
holding a needle parallel to the arm
rapidly and repeatedly
press the point through the drop of
vaccine against the skin about thirty
times in five seconds
a properly performed vaccination should
not result in bleeding
wipe off excess vaccine and do not apply
a dressing
the empty vial plastic dispenser the
protective cover and later the syringe
when it is empty contains stable live
vaccinia virus
before disposal burn
boil or autoclave them to prevent
accidental inoculation of people who may
come in contact with these items
dispose of used needles in the same way
would you step up here now please
the smallpox vaccination is read between
the seventh and ninth day but usually on
the seventh day
a major reaction indicative of virus
propagation
is shown when there is a persisting
lesion that exhibits evidence of current
active inflammation
such as vesiculation
induration spreading erythema or edema
would you step up here please
a minor reaction may show a fairly
marked central lesion or crust but does
not show surrounding active inflammation
there may be a fading erythema but no
edema induration or vesiculation
re-vaccinate all subjects who show a
minor reaction
examination of the re-vaccination is not
normally necessary where freeze-dried
vaccine is used unless the subject is
likely to be exposed to smallpox
infection
in that case examine the subject seven
to nine days later and vaccinate a third
time if he does not show a major
reaction
the present method of interpreting the
results of vaccination was developed
after it was discovered that the former
so-called immune reaction could indicate
either true immunity or only allergy
resulting from the vaccination
on international certificates of
vaccination
major reactions should be entered as
successful vaccinations
minor reactions can also be entered as
successful after re-vaccinating
individuals having such reactions
a note of caution
individuals with skin disorders such as
eczema
or atopic dermatitis
may develop generalized vaccinial
lesions
when 5 million persons were vaccinated
in new york city in forty seven
there were forty five cases
and two deaths due to this complication
some of these cases resulted from
accidental inoculation after contact
with vaccinated individuals
another serious complication is
post-vaccinal encephalitis
there were 45 cases and four deaths in
the same vaccination program in new york
city
progression of vaccinial lesions outward
from the vaccination site occurs
infrequently
and is ordinarily associated with a
gamma globulin anemia
ordinarily these complications respond
to early administration
of vaccinia immune globulin
v
i g
this product is prepared from a sierra
of recently vaccinated individuals
and is stocked at certain red cross
blood centers throughout the united
states
in the user medical general laboratory
in europe and the 406 medical general
laboratory in japan
it is available to military physicians
but because it is limited in supply
prior approval for its release must be
obtained from either the director of the
division of communicable disease and
immunology walter reed army institute of
research washington dc
or one of the designated civilian
control physicians in the united states
civilian control physicians are listed
in the brochure vaccinia immune globulin
published by the american red cross
to avoid delay the physician in charge
of the case should contact directly by
telephone the director of the division
of communicable disease and immunology
or a civilian control physician
he should be prepared to discuss the
clinical and epidemiological features of
the case in order that an adequate
decision can be made
if specific therapy is indicated the
control physician will call the nearest
red cross blood center stocking vig
and arrange for its expeditious delivery
to the requesting physician
we have seen that smallpox comes in many
forms
variola major or classical smallpox with
its varying degrees of severity
variola miner or elastrum
which although milder mimics the
classical case
and a modified form of smallpox seen in
patients who are partially immune
smallpox can be conquered
dr mg kandao director general of the
world health organization
speaking recently at the johns hopkins
medical school said
smallpox is the one disease that can be
eradicated from the earth
completely
absolutely
and forever
[Music]
food
you